each quadrant of the mood meter is
associated with different kinds of
thinking and learning activities when
students are in the yellow they may
experience emotions that promote
creative thinking and the generation of
new ideas brainstorming energetic group
activities and creative problem-solving
are best done in the yellow when
students are in the red they may
experience emotions that heighten
awareness and keep students on their
toes the red is good for competitive
activities like debating or passionate
expression like promoting a cause when
students are in the blue they may
experience emotions that help them focus
for deductive reasoning and critical
thinking in addition the blue emotions
prime students to relate well to others
misfortune building empathy the blue
promotes success for tasks like
proofreading editing and detailed
analysis when students are in the green
they may experience emotions that
promote self-reflection and consensus
building students feel comfortable
relaxed and calm activities that involve
collaboration are ideal for the green
the best teachers differentiate
instruction using the mood meter and
capitalize on all quadrants knowing that
all emotions matter
[Music]